好 那謝謝大家 那個新年好
我聖誕到新年一直在修正
我其實聖誕到新年的時候 市場變化還是蠻大的
特別是acquity 股票
然後股票有很大的幅度的這個上下起伏
而且我說幾個吧 一個是股票
然後利率和外匯上 特別是外匯也經過
就是突破Range Bank 突破了一個區間
每個人走強的 他不光是對人民幣在走強
他對了外匯 對了歐元 對了議員都在走強
我們2025年第一次 展望一下未來一年
就像我上次 好像我講過好幾次
就說2023年是AI的年份
就所有2022年年底的時候出來到GPT
然後轉換為2023年整個股票市場
對於AI概念的追捧
然後2024年的延續了2023年這過程
但是2024年最主要是要宏觀市場
大家都在關注宏觀上美國會不會走落
美國會不會軟著落
然後經濟情況會怎麼樣
然後通常能不能被控制住
所以大家的關注點就在經濟數據在美聯儲
這個我上次應該簡單說過這個事情
然後2025年在我們叫Year of Transformation
Policy Transformation 就是政策的改變
中國政策還有美國政策
那麼政策的改變就必然導致
這個東西是有很大的不確定性的
甚至很多時候在政客的一念之間
或者是在你們在12月底的時候
也看到Decidine的這個鬧局 對吧
那麼雖然共和黨控制了整個議會
或者宏觀來是多數吧
那麼就是通過議會的時候
並沒有像川普他們預期的這麼容易
所以我們會預期
明年的很多政策也會有很多的變數
他們是政策變化一年
但是中間也會有很多的波折
有很多的地方需要協調
這就意味著整個市場一定會面臨了很大的tell risk
我們說tell risk 就是市場的走勢是有個fat tail
有很大的這個尾部
黑天鵝的尾部風險其實發生的概率被我們想象要大
在四個方面 我之前也一直在說的
政策上對於美國的關稅
但對於移民的政策
移民是帶動美國經濟發展過去幾年
很重要的原因
美國的budget cut到底是沒什麼怎麼去做
那麼根據我現在就是經過Decidine這個事情
就是債務上限這個事情
我對於budget cut沒有那麼擔心
沒有之前那麼擔心
所以你可以說三號尾部的風險變小了
但是歐洲的風險還是非常大
所以這四個事情隨時也會爆發
我們講2025年的市場都會有兩條主線
就第一條我認為是base case
我們base case中間最大的概念叫divergence
就是風化美國和歐洲中國的風化
美國經濟很好
然後美聯儲可能政策會變得相對來說
變偏硬一邊
因為它經濟基本面還是很好
然後特朗普上台之後
它很多的政策可以得到實施
特別是它後期的一些可能會
比如說去檢管
去檢管甚至它發很多事情
它可能會發總統令
我們待會會講到
它在能源上面的政策
也可能會發總統令
那麼這些都對於acquity市場
對於市場是一個偏好的
而且我們可以說大部分的科技
或者是新興的技術的項目
都是在美股
所以美國的資本市場
可能還會大概率的還是會走得不錯
那麼配合著美國經濟變強
divergence就是美國 versus中國和歐洲
歐洲和中國都是政策和經濟衰落在跑
這什麼意思呢
就是當我的經濟會變得更差的時候
我的政策的支持的力度
我們特別是財政政策支持的力度
能不能擠得上我經濟變壞的速度
這個是歐洲和中國都面臨的問題
日本的想法
就是我通脹預期上升
那麼我的貨幣政策去控制通脹預期
能不能擠上通脹的預期
所以divergence是我們主線的可能
就是base case
那麼但是這中間有30%的概率
這個是非常不曉得概率
30%的概率可能會發生一些tel risk
tel risk的來源
就可能是policy transformation
有政策的一些變化
所以我就是非常非常宏觀的
說一下就明年我對於整個市場的看法
那麼在這個過程中間
就是資產就說配置的時候
是謹慎和激進並存的
什麼意思呢
就比方說我自己的acquired position
acquired投算
可能我中間有很大程度上
是放了leap call
然後加上一部分陷阱
感覺這個是就是
對於資產配置的一個簡單的看法
那麼說到上個星期
上個星期其實
CTA並沒有破CTA的一些關鍵的點位
所以我們看到Christmas的時候
有很多的gama position在清算
我們看到股票啥股票的gama
從我大概上次講這個市場之前
大概一個月不到吧
那個時候最多的gama position
從Dela那邊看
大概是12.3個別人
123億美元
那很大
總一個點
估值總一個點
那它要對沖
對沖這麼大金額
所以基本上整個估值
都是被控制在這個範圍裡面
但是
很有大量的那個期權
在年底要到期
再加上呢
整個年底的市場交易的時候的
這個投算非常清淡
那麼gama position最後被flip
到了年初的時候1月3號
那麼我看1月3號的時候
可能是變成負的300個別人
所以gama position被flip
然後再加上acquity
就是股票的交易非常清淡
那麼這種情況下
所有的市場會變得非常波動力很大
就是你一買它就包漲
然後一賣它就暴跌
那就是S&P在上個月的
基本上的走勢
所以我在休假中間
好像還跟好幾個投資人簡單
因為那天好像是聖誕後吧
聖誕後的那天跌了很凶
所以好幾個投資人
我跟他也聊過幾個
就是說在聖誕期間這個市場
你可以不要去看它
因為它就是一個
這個價錢沒有意義
價錢帶上量才有意義
它沒有量
所以它就是擺個盤
往下跌一下之後還會反彈
那麼更大程度上是因為positioning
那麼但是我覺得
就新年
聖誕之後到新年
這一次的比較大的調整
很短期的一個
那天跌了很多
那這樣一個幅度的調整
其實對於美股是一個好事
因為在這個調整中間
把很多
我們本來覺得
倉位過重了
就是美股倉位過重
一直是美股
我覺得是一個風險
那麼把很多過重的倉位
一定程度上清掉
所以整個acquity selling
在那一個星期
大概是191
那這中間有一些包括就年底的時候
他們要挑倉
要把那個only給realize出來
要把only給弄出來
然後也包括中間很多
那個gamma的hatch
gamma position of flip
都包括大概出來
大概191
所以現在呢
整個我們會看
比在進入
在我說有風險有風險
大概是在這個時候吧
對吧
是在那個聖誕前
比聖誕前的時候
倉位稍微健康一點
這個是
這個是市場一個大事的一個情況
那麼這個股票的下跌
並沒有就包括
gamma的
gamma投存的變化
並沒有完全導致
cta去大規模的拋敗
然後昨天和今天兩天的走勢
可能會讓cta再買回來
所以總體來說
我們看到看年的這個情況
在這個短期的tactic
不能說太遠
就是沒人看得準
但是tactic上來看
我覺得在trump上任之前
市場應該還算不錯
這就跟我們上一次講的比較
比較一致
就是1月前兩星期
通常都是不少基金
在新年的時候
他會把投存清掉
然後前一兩星期
都是重新配置的一兩星期
基本上基金流露會
相對來說比較多一點
那麼我們從很短期的tactic上來看
可能還是等特朗普上台
看他的政策
其實大家都還在看他的政策
那麼今年政策面
影響會非常大
那麼這是一個
然後第二就是我們看到
其實比較重要的是
我想說的是fx
外匯
外匯的破位是
日元歐元、人民幣都在破位
在過去一個月裡面
其實突破了過去挺長時間
一段時間的range bond的空間
所以我們會看到美元走強
美元走強對於所有風險資產
都不是一個特別好的事情
那麼這背後的原因
其實也是年底的position
因為其實在trump剛剛選上的時候
就有不少對沖基金
他們都買了很多
就是long dollar option
就是買看多美元的期權
各種各樣的看多美元期權
那麼這個有中間很多代結構
那麼在年底的時候
因為頭寸比較輕
然後市場流動性比較差
所以一旦上漲的時候
他就把很多option的barrel給計穿了
每次計穿option barrel這些
你就相當於想把gama war給計穿了
計穿之後市場就會順著那個方向
繼續大幅的往上漲
所以美元在去年底到今年
就今年初之前漲了不少
那麼這個漲幅
我覺得是somehow是可以延續的
為什麼
因為我們已經在flow上
可以看到不少real money
因為前一段時間的上漲
更多的是hatch fund
我們叫leverage money
就槓桿錢在拉動
但是real money已經開始stopping to long dollar
就是說他們被迫的去做多美元
包括有很多外貿的資金
他們開始減少美元的對沖
那麼在歐洲在日本
在中國其實美元對沖已經一直比較少
但是在歐洲在日本或者是在其他地方
這些美元對沖的減少已經比較明顯
現在這個幅度是不是說
美元已經漲到頂
其實我覺得沒有
舉個例子
我們看到歐元對美元的implial
大概從3個月implial
從6%到8%
然後8%其實相比
川普上一屆搞貿易戰什麼的時候
那有時候可能是到了10%
10%
所以我們只是說
fxball在過去一段時間裡面
就是去年的時候
去年相當長的一段時間裡面
還是在一個非常低的位置
就是說我們市場開始
終於開始在特朗普要上台的時候
開始pricing
外匯可能會波動
那麼這個外匯的波動
一方面對應的特朗普可能會有的
這個tariff
就是那個外貿關稅的政策
那麼另一方面
還是對應的歐洲和美國
就從主線來講
tail risk不算
從主線來講
歐洲和美國或者是中國和美國的
這個
divergence
就是他們的這個分分離不同
那麼在歐洲來看的話
我們會看到它經濟會變得更差
所以三月份的時候
有可能我們會看到
美聯儲停止降息
然後歐洲會繼續降息
然後英國可能會再降息
所以你看到就是說
歐中央行和英格蘭銀行
它對於美聯儲的
貨幣政策的divergence
也是會存在
從這個角度上來講
就是說我們會看到
更多的real money
實際就是實際做外貿的錢
投資的錢
那麼這些錢
都會慢慢的減少
對於美聯的對寵
那麼這個是可能會
美元栽培了一年
繼續變得
趨勢性的變得更強的一個可能
那麼
我覺得甚至對歐元道義
那麼這個都是一個
比較fair的價錢
就是歐元道義
那麼日元要看
日本的那個生息的情況
人民幣是一個
非常被控制的currency
中間我們這裡大部分都還是
有很多人民幣資產的
然後人民幣是一個
非常被控制的資產
那麼在人民幣上的
我講一個人民幣
impliable就是那個波動率的一個情況
人民幣的波動率
在大概一個月的時候是5.8
然後在6個月的時候
就到了6.7
其實這個wall的區別
代表的市場pricing
你在短期裡面會控制人民幣
然後你在6個月裡面控制不住
那麼這個
跟我對人民幣的判斷也是差不多
所以你在短期裡面
可能還在7.2
7.2其實這個threshold
已經被打破了
可能還是在7.2到7.3上下
但是在6個月的時候
其中它很有可能會到
7.4、7.5的生命
或者在一年走期裡
那個7.4到7.5
還是我看大概幾年
一年人民幣的這個位置
比如說
中間大號會有比較大的波折
就是2月份的時候
它會有比較大幅的下跌
可能Trump的政策出來
Trump的所有的Tariff的政策
它不一定會馬上實施的
總統令和立法是兩件事情
立法是需要一年的過程的
然後甚至到一年
幾個月到一年的過程
但是總統令可以馬上出
它是說它要在Tariff上面
出總統令的
那麼我覺得可能真的出的
只有這種
對其他國家未必會針出來
但是實施它也是會有空間的
所以2月份的時候
也有很多負面的新聞
可能會出來
從美國和中國的外貿上
那麼這個負面的東西
會帶動人民幣變弱
那麼之後可能會
中國的政策
可能會帶動Tariff Cover
但是從趨勢上來講
它就是7.4到7.5
因為美元走強
還是主線上
還是大的趨勢
那麼有什麽東西會讓這個變改變呢
就是我們講到的Tale Risk
萬一美國衰退
美國所有我覺得最大的Tale Risk
在明年政策上Tale Risk
就是不管什麽政策
導致美國經濟真的變弱
真的走弱
那麽這個就會
包括我們剛講到基本上
當好我們會說
基本上對債券的判斷
對利率的判斷
對外匯判斷
對股市的判斷
全部要改變
所以這個都是一個Tale Risk
但是正常情況下的美元走強
美元走強會利好美國的市場
但是美元走強
利率會維持一個高位
那麽這種情況下
對於風險資產中間也會諷划
那麽風險資產中間
盈利相對比較好的資產
那麽我覺得是比較看好
是吧
就是但是對於比方說
黃金或者是流動性偏
流動性依靠度很高的
比方說比特幣
它繼續拉盤的壓力會很難
就是因為這輪比特幣基本上
全是靠必安給拉起來的
但是必安把它拉起來之後
繼續維持在這個高位上
沒有那麽容易
所以這個是大致
我覺得這個是
最近的一個外匯的變化
那麽最後我說一下那個
美元利率
先說一下大致宏觀發行的一個情況
那麽在明年的時候
總體要發
US dollar supply
大概在明年的時候
不是明年
就今年2025年的時候
850個免費
就8.5億美元
8.5億美元的那個DBO1
那這個規模其實很大
就是說但是相對2024年會好一點
2024年的時候
大概是就一個別臉
10億美元的DBO1
所以我們會看到總體的發行量
在20預期總體的發行量
在2025年的時候
相對來說變少一些
那麽這個就是inline
我們最近的一個美國的這個
deceiving的事情
額戰物上限呢
其實有一點
可能我覺得有一點
出乎那個GOP的預期
因為GOP還是需要那個就是共和黨吧
共和黨還是需要
雖然他們在那個議會
眾議院有多數議席
就是微弱的多數
但是他還是
他要通過政策
還是需要和黨內的保守派去溝通呢
所以黨內的保守派
對於整個美國赤字的情況
包括對於美國以後還會有
就對於美國移民
對於美國那個tariff怎麽樣
他的這個
他的這個觀點
和黨內的激進盤是不一樣的
就是森浩你會覺得吧
就是整個這次大選選贏
是一群對民主黨
特別是對民主黨的這個
膨脹不滿意的人
或者對民主黨這個
王左走DIE啊
威國啊這些事情做了時代
時代不能忍受的幫人
那麽聯合起來
把民主黨給選下來
把拜登政府選下來
但是在共和黨黨內
他們的分歧
在某些議題上
甚至比對民主黨的
這個分歧還要更大
我記得應該是Christmas前後吧
然後在那個推了上面
Elon Musk
就是Elon Musk其實是代表
那個共和黨內的這個
規股派
就是他們是科技派
包括Elon Musk
包括Peter Thiel
我們上次講到
美國政治的時候
其實說過這個話題
其實那個川普
他背後真正的老闆
是Peter Thiel
是代表著那個規股的利益
那麽這批人呢
其實他對於移民政策和MAGA
MAGA就是得幫紅脖子
就是我們把紅脖子
統稱為MAGA
那幫MAGA派
他們是有本質的這個區別的
所以他們在那個
推特上發生爭吵
爭吵之後
其實川普最後是
占了Elon Musk的便
就是把MAGA
他那些基本盤也拋棄了
所以你可以理解
比如說
有一部分人是底層的
有一部分人是規股的新規
這些人聯合起來
把那個川普給選上去了
但是他們之間
對於很多政策的分歧
會很大
所以不要覺得共和黨
通控制了議會
然後他就能夠隨心所欲的
通過所有的政策
其實並沒有那麽容易
包括我們這一次
也看到那個
特朗普對House的控制力
比我們想象的要弱
比如說這一次
只是突破Decide
現在是最後當然Compromise
就是說
一方面他引用了
原來的一些政策
就是說我可以
這個財政部引用了
所以財政部其實可以
把那個發財規模
就手上的現金規模
TGA的規模用在700個別臉
就7000億左右
所以這個7000億左右的
TGA是可以讓美國
大概用到7月份
所以創不上臺之後
很有可能在3月份
沒比在3月份的時候
就把這些問題解決掉
但是通過Deciline的難度
一定比他減稅的難度要小
所以他要說
他後面去
比方說去搞減稅這些事情
很有可能
GOP還是需要和Democrats
在議會裏面要協調
說島內有一些保守派
未必會完全統一
很多減稅的政策
所以當你很多
你假如說你Budget
需要去和Democrats溝通的時候
那麼就會增加溝通的難度
就Luckily
我們希望在3月份的時候
那麼我們把Deciline
這些事情全部能解決掉
但是也有種可能
就是你需要和民主黨去溝通
去民主黨去協調
那麼這個事情
就往往會拖到最後一步
因為不同黨的
大家利益訴求
民主黨比方說
有可能會要求你把
奧巴馬KL中間一部分東西保留
那麼這些東西
是一旦需要協調
它有可能會把時間脫後
就有可能在政策上
造成不確定性
所以
我就說最簡單的
通過一些條款的政策
並沒有像現在想像的
這麼簡單
我們對於Deciline和對於發展
我們可以看真正的
債務上限的時間
大概就是今年的7月份
這次
無論如何
它畢竟是黨內的協調
所以無論如何
它不會搞得像23年
或者像10年之前
奧巴馬那個時候
什麼Government shutdown
然後Deciline 鬧出一個大鬧局
股票暴跌
這種事情
我覺得不太會發生
但是呢
我們也要同時
預期到有很多的政策實施中間
是會有glitch的
是會有一些
小的波動
那麼
會說回整個發展的規模
所以在這過程中
如果正常的情況下
2025年的發展呢
是相對來說
比2024年稍微好一點
所以我在2024年年初的時候
就一直覺得
長債利率下不去
無論如何都下不去
2025年有發展的規模
但2026年會不小
雖然這規模比2024年小
但是利率不會
不會大幅下降
特別是現在美聯儲
還雖然比較強硬
那即使美聯儲
到時候
沒有像現在想的這麼強硬
它的這個下去的也是短端
所以對利率
我整體的看法
還是steep
變抖
也就是說
在短端是有機會的
短端是個美食的概念
就是說
現在大家開始pricing
明年不降息了
然後或者是降息很少
那麼等到重新開始pricing
不是明年
我那個休假日子過魂
今年就是大家開始pricing
2025年
這樣有一部分開始pricing
2025年降很少息
降一次或者降1.5次
當它開始重新認識到
今年可能還是會降兩次息的時候
我覺得今年至少還是要降兩次息
很有可能6月份一次
年底下會降一次
那麼從一次變回兩次
那麼在這個短端
可能還是利率曲線
還是會往下跑一些
但是長端上供應還是並不小的
特別是1月份
我看到1月份的供應
大概是比第一季度的預期要
第一季度
一季度的預期是73個million
就是7300萬
我講的都是DBO1
就是債權都是講DBO1
就是7300萬DBO1
一季度的供應
大概是9000萬DBO1
所以1月份的供應
大概9000萬DBO1
所以在這幾天
一直到後面表示
1月底的時候
利率對於實驗期
對於長端的利率的壓力
還是在的
所以整個利率
我覺得今年還是會偏Steepen變抖
然後長端會維持在這個水平
現在這個水平相對來說
是一個比較fair的水平
那麼這個水平
其實已經對所有風險資產
是非常不友好
我們可以看他們去
比方說他們拉盤比的幣的時候
那個長端利率可是在4左右
所以差不多在4左右
拉盤比的幣的時候
所以比的幣是一個非常標準的
非常依靠流動性的資產
所以你要繼續在維持這個資產的價格
你用人為拉通的方法去維持這個資產價格
其實難度沒有那麼低
是有一定難度的
這個我大概就這樣
對今年的市場
我一定要說明年
對今年市場這樣展望一下
所以看看大家有些什麼問題
然後那個我回答一下
好那謝謝大家時間
沒什麼問題的話我就先這樣了
好拜拜
大家新年快樂
對我說A股跌得很厲害
就是我我我我我12月中的時候
就說A股要跌
A股在那個特朗普上臺前和上臺前後
都是一個比較比較
比較不是很很樂觀的一個狀態
但是但是我覺得是這樣
就是你你這樣講
A股是這樣就是說
政治局會議是醫生給你開藥
然後那個那個兩會之後實行
它是去藥房拿藥
市場預期你已經大出血了
醫生就直接給你藥了
但醫生沒給
所以整個市場就跌得很兇
那你到了美國
你等於往下走的時候
又被人家統一到
美國到時候又統一到
所以大出血出了更嚴重
那到了開藥的時候
他們會有一波的relief的
但是今年中國
為什麼叫政策也叫追趕
就是說我們控制通縮的政策
是不是急得上通縮的速度
這個追趕的速度
是要一步一步擠上的
現在肯定是擠不上
後面還要看看能不能擠上
好謝謝謝謝
嗯拜拜